you can actually only something of Jones
well I heard audible is that gave our
senior news editor a private look at the
items which meant so much to her mom
this is my department and it's very
grand I live very very very well that's
a start with I enjoy my creature
comforts my brother was a maximalist
which means she had a lot of stuff there
she a hoarder and some sort she was a
maximalist like I said rich people
hoarding um you know she never is a tag
sale or an antique shop or an auction
she couldn't find something at a house
is pretty my house is very my house
Joan invited us home so many times over
the years the closets the jewelry boxes
yeah she was kind of a secret hoarder
from this pink and black lace gown
opening bid 1202 this ruffled Cape dress
she wore to the 1990 Toni's 220 pieces
of her designer clothing jewels and
furniture up for auction now on display
at Christie's New York so everybody
remembers this dress for the 2003 Emmys
I mean she just beautiful that night a
lot of feathers we have an assortment of
different jewelry here a Judith Leiber
bag her jewelry I think is so special I
once said to her I love your earrings
and she took them off her ears they can
say well because they were from her QVC
yeah and give them to your grandmother
ten thousand can get you this emerald
and amethyst necklace it was one of
Joan's favorites on the red carpet also
in the 186 page catalog miniature dogs
perhaps modeled after her own beloved
pooches right but there are a few things
Melissa just couldn't let go off I kept
everything that was on her night table
my favorite room is my bedroom my
bedroom was total fantasy and your son
did we get to keep anything from her he
got to pick anything he wanted to keep
if you're very good I'll buy a new one
for you birthday and on my visit with
Melissa last year I learned of one
poignant gift Cooper gave Joan as she
was about to pass it has baseball hat
with him and he here I go down and he
went in the other room
and he took his baseball hat and he put
it in her hands and he said please make
sure this stays with her and I made sure
that it it never left her say it's been
almost two years since Joan passed away
and seeing all of her treasures we have
this take away from her life dress-up
use the good China you are worth it
suddenly now I'm setting the table every
night I am using the her dishes I love
having a friend of friends come over for
dinner having a pretty dinner with the
good dishes
she loved living a gracious and
beautiful type of life that's so
important
thank you all for being here and I thank
God for another one with a basket you're
here